yep hello and welcome to this video
playing it FM flashlight and we cut some
some trompe yeah this is a gambit hmm
and I don't know what I mean I don't
know how it is played let's be solid
about this I'm probably getting some
French this is not exactly the
refutation of this but yeah I don't want
to spend ages try to figure it out and
maybe I'm not getting getting much
anyway if i try to i'm playing this
inner in the typical french defence
style this is some setup that i have
played long time ago we're still
regularly was playing the French and
it's not um well it's not the greatest
ever but it's a it's a playable option
this kind of setup is purely defensive
but you sometimes get chances on the
queenside and maybe I mean his CP
players played the Trump is not an e4
player so we'll see how well he handles
this I mean I'm not great on the black
site of the French either but still
we'll see what happens okay I'm from the
rook c8 Ian
yeah I would love to get some grip on
the c4 square
it's not yet possible okay so he wants
to do with something aggressive down the
Kings side not sure yet what the
sacrifices shouldn't work yet but if I
go Bishop c6 for example and then the
sacrifice might might work yeah but I
would like to connect rooks but
currently doesn't look possible okay
I'll try to go to g7 not seeing any
sacrifices at the moment but I mean
something like f5 I can take 25 though
okay so what is the point of this move
and maybe he wants to play g5 they have
AG 5 f-5 I mean I'm sorry okay bringing
that why i can now invade down but first
let's go King g7 I mean let's see for us
what I'm talking about okay just has
cleared to see file so i can go here i
really want to make sure that some night
f seven or so it's not happening I've
lost my fair share of games in the in
the French in this kind of this kind of
way just having less space and then they
sacrifice and kill me
I mean nights you for checking you three
I'm just attacking this so that King g3
is not so easily possible yeah let's go
back to trade trade things I can trade
some pieces I'm not in in that bad shape
here main danger is a checkmate really
some some brutal attack okay I can go to
be three here yeah III he blundered a
three but can I take it it's the
question yeah i think i can actually yep
that was clear and now Bishop e8 it's
still dangerous so dangerous I don't
know it might be just bad for me it's
possible but there was also I simply
could not not take a three it's what
then you have to do if they give you the
opportunity ok so here a couple of
possible sacrifices are around the
corner
should be seven i guess and i might you
might still have some sacrifice anyway
night is six something there's a five
and that's this okay i'm taking on h4
the screen g6 instead winning time
morning queen g6 kingvale there might be
some mate ok check I don't see yet i'm
losing here but maybe i am i think i can
go around with anyway even if it's not
working objectively hit super dangerous
threatening made myself but term it's
probably not a big issue for him when I
it's got to be six then huh
yeah it's made with Bishop h7 added
initiative on the king size always super
dangerous check black resigns yeah
that's it I just hate those positions I
really have to say I hate it I've played
played there's a lot over while in
tournament shares and it's just terrible
wyd always has the space and can can
poke around on the Kings side and it's
very difficult to defend even if it's
sometimes okay it's just super dangerous
to play I mean here i have no idea it
might might have been just good for him
it might have been not working but it's
just impractical play it sir it's it's
super awful and he also just blundered a
three but it's just so dangerous what
can you do yeah because this attack is
just very dangerous what is the engine
giving here night see one with equality
great move very easy to play well ok I
played here and no already night have
seven does win John I went here and my
practical player cannot defend us the
engine just goes night see one it says
door 000 probably seeing some kind of
perpetual but ok this is also a matter
of how how how deep the engine is going
it might find a win for wide if you let
it run longer you cease attacking with
lots of pieces after this I'm losing
right after work after this yeah it's
it's not defensible
now this you're you're walking a
tightrope with this this is kind of
Defense IAM night see one is the engine
move him Jim so also somewhat difficult
to figure out should be oneness what did
the he played that now the engine gives
this we had move for maybe Bishop d3 now
that's completely inhuman nobody plays
like like this this is what the engine
is giving that night running around and
it's supposed to be equal but it's not
something that is relevant to practical
plane and practical play this position
is just bad for black because you yeah
maybe I should just take stuff here
maybe I should just take stuff this is
probably a better practical choice yeah
this actually looks kind of okay because
he now also doesn't get the Queen over
that quickly and if I can hear I can't
chance is to maybe even trade Queens
yeah that seems ok that seems ok really
for black especially in practical player
and it doesn't help if the engine gives
giving some kind of weird defense that
you can never find but this this looks
kind of okay yeah and this is this
gambit line here this is something that
I probably have to check it's it's not
supposed to be very good but I don't I
never looked never checked it so II six
was more of a chicken out more fear than
anything else I don't know what what is
right here c5 maybe that do something
like this looks right yeah I would need
to check it that is probably
maybe this is better than going into
that kind of French French position okay
well thanks for watching